what do you call a group of cats
let me check on that
it's called a clouder of cats
if you have a question any question
there's a number you can call
[Music]
917-275
and a librarian at the new york public
library will try to answer it for you
hello thanks for calling ask nypl
we have 10 librarians on the team and we
answer any question that you may have
over the telephone
in the office today we have matthew
bernard serena diane and me
our department ask nypl began in 1967.
we started answering questions over the
telephone but people have been reaching
out to librarians for as long as there
have been libraries
the new york public library has actually
saved records of some of the more
interesting questions they've been asked
over the years
like is there a full moon every night in
acapulco
why do 18th century english paintings
have so many squirrels in them and how
do they tame them so they wouldn't bite
the painter
are plato aristotle and socrates one in
the same person
in a world of google it's a bit
surprising to know that they get around
30 000 calls per year
my question is why
oftentimes people
might not have access to the technology
at home
and i honestly think some just want
somebody to talk to
so the next time you have a question
like how many teeth does a great white
shark have you can call this number
917-275
that'll ring inside of this building
up on this floor and maybe bernard or
rosa will pick up
and they'll answer it for you
they have about 300 serrated teeth
[Music]
you